and i remember holding my friend's hand
that was the last thing i remember doing
she was in the aisle seat next to mine
and that was like the last thing i did
the last person i looked at spoke to on
that plane and then it was just it was
just darkness i assume at that point
that's when the plane actually crashed
it was december 10 2005 i was 16 years
old and i was a high school student i
was in my senior year of high school i
went to a boarding school which was in
the capital of nigeria which is where i
was born and raised and i was in school
i was on campus this was the end of the
semester and
myself and
students who lived in the same area as
me we typically board the same plane to
go home to come back to the campus
because the school is made up of
students who live all over nigeria so we
usually like come from different parts
of the country to get to the school
flying was nothing unusual you know i
mean it was part of life for us so this
was just like a routine trip essentially
there was nothing that would indicate
what was to come there was no reason to
think anything weird would happen it was
a regular commercial bullying jet and i
was sitting in front i was in one of the
i was in the an aisle seat in front and
next to me was one of my closest friends
she was also in the aisle seat and then
the pilot made the announcement that we
would be landing soon over the intercom
which they usually do and then the
descent started and that was when the
turbulence started and i remember it was
just you know regular turbulence no one
nothing weird it happens on flight it's
not a big deal you know and it just kept
getting worse and prolonged and i just
remember like the rising tension in the
cabin no one was saying anything no one
was screaming or anything like that
but like
it was palpable you know just the
feeling in the air that like
you know we're all thinking like what
the heck is going on
and then there was like this scream from
the back of the plane it was like it was
a woman she screamed
and at that point that was just like all
that was needed for the chaos to just
kind of like erupt it was like a movie
it was literally like i was in a movie
and i was watching this happen it felt
very surreal
and it was just unbelievable i just
couldn't believe i was in that situation
and i remember holding my friend's hand
that was the last thing i remember doing
she was in the aisle sit next to mine
and that was like the last thing i did
the last person i looked at spoke to
on that plane and then it was just it
was just darkness i assume at that point
that's when the plane actually crashed
but i don't remember the actual impact
you know i just remember that metals
creeping irritating sound like nails on
chalkboard and then i i blacked out
and it was just darkness until
until i was opening my eyes and i was in
the hospital bed in south africa
and five weeks had passed and i was weak
enough from a coma i was told later on
that the plane crashed and exploded no
one except two people survived
[Music]
i was flown to south africa the day
after the accident after um they had
stabilized me in the hospital in nigeria
but they have to fly me out asap because
we did not have the facilities we had
the the people
you know brilliant doctors but no
facility equipped to care for third
degree burns i sustained third degree
burns over
65 of my body so it was a very dire
situation so they have to get me out of
there as soon as possible to a place
that could actually give me a chance to
survive i opened my eyes and
i saw the nurse that was talking to me
and i saw my mom and i knew what had
happened
why
because while i was in a coma my mom
would talk to me she would talk to me
over and over she would tell me what had
happened where i was and that i was
gonna be okay i could hear her i could
hear everything she said so when i
opened my eyes i knew where i was i knew
what had happened
and you know i believed that i was gonna
be okay because you know my mom said i
was gonna be okay
i started asking questions you know
about the intensity of my burns where
wasn't i burned you know what part of me
was not affected
there were not a lot you know um and
even those areas you know where now
like they look like they were burned
because they had used skin from those
areas to cover the rest of me
over and over so those areas kind of
scarred over and um yeah i just kind of
i took stock of how bad it was
and just kind of tried my best to roll
with it and
um i guess just not be too affected by
the fact that i was so different
physically now i just focused more on
like
the healing part of things which was
hard enough honestly on its own so 65
third-degree burns that's basically
everything from the top of my head to
the soles of my feet burning except for
my torso my my tummy oh and my butt too
so they took skin from my tummy and my
back and my butt to like cover up the
main areas that burned every which was
like everywhere else literally
the most important thing in the
beginning was to cover up the large
surface areas that were
burned off third degree means burning
down to your dermis not just the top
layer but the bottom layer of the skin
and in some areas down to the bone as
well it's literally like you like be
naked but like for the body because when
your skin is not on you then you are
exposed to every kind of infection
and that can be what ends up killing a
person as opposed to like the actual
trauma that you know took your skin does
the pain of the actual accident of the
injuries and then and then the pain of
the healing injuries
my pain was being managed very severely
in that in those earlier moments i was
barely feeling anything not even not
just pain but just feeling in general it
was a very floaty cloudy time like the
first two months or so i was mostly kept
under i was i was sleeping more than i
was awake during that time this is even
after weakness from the coma
so
with
the recovery came
more feeling more sensation
and
it was just really hell it was just you
know the more alive i was the more pain
i was in so that so my family was like
like very supportive and encouraging and
just present there
and then the rest of the world was very
supportive of my family
including those who lost their kids
because you know that was like i think
one of the heart if not the hardest part
of like dealing with all this was like
just um coming to terms with the fact
that like all these other kids that were
on the plane with me all my classmates
were gone and um some of them had all
their children in my school like in the
same school and literally lost all their
kids in one go so painful to think about
how they had all lost their kids you
know and
you know it also gave me grounds to not
complain too much because i knew that no
matter how bad things were for me
oldest parents would prefer
to have their kids in my situation than
to just be gone
once surgery stopped and hospital life
was no longer really a thing
it left everything open so now my future
was like now just like a regular future
of like whatever you want it to be and
that at that time i kind of took back
the reins of control rather they were
given back to me and now i could do
whatever i wanted and i didn't have to
plan things around like surgeries or
hospital visits anymore so
in that in that moment i think a
transition happened where
i started trying to live with more
intention and live with more purpose so
um
now i am a singer you know i sing i
travel i perform
i am also a speaker professional speaker
so i do a lot of inspirational
motivational speeches and talks i do a
lot of advocacy work
for bullying prevention
and for other burn survivors
representing burnt survivors you know um
the world over and i only recently was
able to add author to my repertoire of
stuff i guess
this year
with my book called more than my scars i
wrote that it's a memoir the reason i
wrote the book was because i wanted to
be more relatable to people who have
gone through any kind of trauma and i
wanted them to see that they're not
alone in what they're going through you
know i understand from a very personal
point of view and i want people to know
that they're not alone you know i feel
like the more you realize you're not
alone in something the more you feel
like okay then maybe you know
there's there's a sense of like um
companionship when you're going through
something with people
it's more likely you're gonna get
through it i guess you know and i want
people to feel that way when they read
my book so
[Music]
we fly and we hope like it doesn't crash
and that
that ship has sailed with me so for me
it was like
it's already happened we've already
experienced the worst thing that can
possibly happen from flying so um yeah
i'm just i'm pretty sure
it's done you know it's
lightning sometimes it strikes in the
same area twice but it's unlikely so i
just kind of see like that you know if
you want to do things and go around you
know you can
you're not going to be able to live the
full life that you promised everyone
you're going to live if you can only go
to places that you drive to like you're
not you will be very limited if that's
how you decide to live your life can't
you so
you know i feel like i was just like
well you know it's part of life we move
and we just do what we have to do i just
remember him
pulling me back and i was like dad
please help me please help me he just
kept going i got you i got you i got you
so we get most of the way back to shore
he's carrying me but you know he just
punched a shark like five times so i
didn't see the shark and i don't think
anybody saw the shark they might have
just saw the fins
um
but
um after my dad was like carrying me
back he says he saw two fins so there
were two sharks